there's an asterisk in the title of this
video of course there's an asterisk
there has to be and I'll be honest I had
a whole script ready to go here as the
sun sets over the Atacama Desert in
Chile
but I've found so much more than I
expected over the last day and a half so
many stories I've been exhausted both
from the altitude with three kilometers
up here and from dashing around with
handheld cameras trying to capture
everything so what's going to happen now
is we're going to cut to a version of me
in a couple of weeks time who is
coherent and who's had time to process
all this
here's the story I got an invitation to
visit the extremely large telescope
scientists love giving telescopes names
like that it's a telescope it's
extremely large the invite was from the
UK Science and Technology facilities
Council and the European Southern
Observatory they arrange everything but
they have no editorial control over what
I'm saying and I paid my own travel
those flights were expensive so there'll
be an advert for nordvpn later on
because it was actually useful to me
while I was in Chile anyway the Atacama
Desert is the most desolate place I've
ever been to Rolling Hills of stone and
rock for hour after hour of driving I'm
sure there's life out there somewhere
but we didn't see any of it eventually
we arrive at the base camp at paranal
let me give you the lay of the land at
the bottom of the hill is the residence
where visiting scientists and
non-scientists stay not a hotel very
definitely not a hotel you can't pay for
a room there if you try it's more like
University dorms if University dorms
ever won architectural Awards that's at
the bottom of the hill along with all
the support buildings and structures
that are needed to support life out
there up at the top of the hill is the
very large telescope built about 20
years ago and a few kilometers away a
little dot on a flattened off Hill on
the horizon that's the extremely large
telescope the new one and that's likely
going to be the largest optical
telescope that will ever be built but to
understand why that is I need to show
you around
our first stop is at the very large
telescope the VLT up on the hill about
two kilometers from base camp in theory
you can walk it there's a path called
the star track but I didn't feel like
getting altitude sickness the VLT has
been operational for more than 20 years
now results from it have won Nobel
prizes it was the first telescope to
take an actual picture of a planet
around another star in tested Einstein's
general relativity by tracking a star
around the supermassive black hole at
the center of the Galaxy and it's
actually several telescopes the four big
ones are called the unit telescopes or
UTS and we were visiting ut4 you guys
just going okay oh wow
so a paranalaga four UT telescopes now
these are the the large telescopes we
have here where the premium mirror this
thing you see here underneath here this
is 8.2 meters in diameter and that is a
mirror very very scientifically precise
but the same kind of optical mirror that
you would have just to do your makeup in
the morning or something like that
um yes yes lesson one do not compare the
extremely expensive scientific
instrument to a makeup mirror the
important thing is that the telescopes
here are optical telescopes that's the
first reason for the asterisk there are
already bigger radio telescopes I was
lucky enough to visit Arecibo before the
collapse and I recently visited parks in
Australia they're all much bigger but
they collect radio waves not light they
pick up very different frequencies and
they're useful for observing different
objects and doing different science the
stuff you can do with radio that you
can't do with Optical and vice versa
radio telescopes have to be much larger
because the wavelengths of the
microwaves and radio waves they pick up
range from millimeters to tens of meters
but they don't have to be as precise as
long as you build a big bowl that's a
right shape you don't need to make a
perfect Optical mirror finish it will
still work Arecibo surface was just kind
of rough mesh but that still worked
Optical astronomy looks for visible
light or infrared this stuff we can see
with the naked eye or close to that the
wavelengths are from about 100
micrometers to 100 nanometers and so the
Optics have to be so so precise just
like any other camera lens or actually
more precise because mirrors this big
have other problems when you get to this
large telescopes it's actually extremely
difficult to keep the mirror stable and
in the same position so it has 150
actuators underneath it it's like poking
the mirror ever so that must be microns
that must be a tiny tiny amount of
movement yeah and this is basically to
take into account gravity of the mirror
and temperature distance we have within
here because when you move the mirror
then from Gravity then the shape of the
mirror is also changing as well that's
called active Optics deforming the
mirror ever so slightly to deal with the
effects of gravity as you tilt it and
from thermal expansion as the
temperature changes that's how accurate
this has to be we'll come back to that
later because I got to see the mirror
and those actuators close up but first
we've got to explain what that mirror
actually does but we're getting it ready
for the night so they had to test it
because the whole thing moves oh oh
that's way faster than I thought it was
going to be we basically test the
rotation we test all of the movements of
the telescopes we check for the safety
of the system before we're going to
start the nighttime operations I can't
hear the movement right this is so fast
oh we're going back the other way I'm
just giggling this is several hundreds
tons right it's moving like this and
basically it's kind of floating on top
of this very small amount of oil film so
underneath it because during the night
when we're doing the scientific
observations we may be staying on one
target so observing one Galaxy for
several hours because the Earth is
rotating so therefore we need to move
the telescope so that we keep pointing
at exactly the same position so this
movement needs to be extremely smooth
because we don't want to add any
additional movement onto the
observations
rotation test complete now the Tilt
we're going to open the Dome and we want
to put the mirror in such a way if
anything falls down from the Dome that
the probability of that actually falling
on the mirror is in the middle of the
desert constantly you're having dust
that's accumulating onto the mirror I
mean large things falling onto it
actually is extremely easy I just I just
looked over there oh wow so the light
would come in from a star yes hit the
main mirror which is be reflective the
big reflective thing there back to M2
just here exactly and then down to M3 in
the middle it can rotate to send it to
any two at the instrument or it opens to
send it to the instrument that's below
right there's a lot of very bad
animations out there which show
satellite transmissions and stuff like
that beaming not into the bowl of the
dish but to the detector the thing that
sticks out and that is the wrong way
round that's really important light
bounces off M1 the bowl and gets focused
onto the focal point and then here it
gets bounced down again either to the
equipment at the sides or down into the
basement lights can come in and hit M1
yes but isn't M2 in the way of what
you're trying to observe no it doesn't
because you have parallel light beams
that are arriving to the M1 it's not
going to come across on camera I don't
think but there is quite a little white
Mark just there a lot of dust on the
mirror how much is that going to affect
the observations for any given object of
a given brightness as the mirror gets
dirtier then you'll have to observe for
longer to get the same amount of light
on your detector so we recall the mirror
once every two or three years to
maintain the reflectivity they do use
dry ice to dust the mirrors every few
weeks but that can't get everything that
builds up over time dust on the mirror
doesn't change the Optics it doesn't
spoil the image it just means that
sunlight isn't reflected at all so over
time the image gets less and less bright
I did get to see the mirror recoating
lab later they just start to clean one
of the other telescope mirrors the one
from ut1 and when I arrived at the lab
the first thing I saw was the structure
they used to transport the whole thing
down the hill how on Earth did you get
that thing all the way down the hill
from ut1 first we have to disconnect the
cell from the main structure of the
telescope and then we put this structure
on the yellow part you can see which is
the carriage and this Carriage is put on
top of a truck and we drive like three
kilometers this system is over air
cushions and we can move with the air
cushions wait it's a hovercraft yeah
it's basically a Hovercraft
same same principle because the mirror
is not here right now maybe we can go up
yeah yeah let's go up yeah absolutely so
what you can see from up top is the
telescope without the mirror on it the
mirror I thought was kind of a bold
shape but this looks flat to me the
saggy is not so high it's like 30
centimeter so it looks flat but it's
sphere okay it's just a section of a
very big sphere exactly you can imagine
that if we make the full ball out of
this mirror it will be a ball of 60
meter diameter so let's go see the
mirror being cleaned they've moved it
into the clean room next door and to
start with it was just being washed also
I realize I look stupid with the hoodie
on under the clean room gown and first
it's not a medical or semiconductor
grade clean room they assure me it's
fine and second the reason I'm always in
the hoodie is that we're always going
out and in so the temperature was always
switching from cold air conditioned
interior to brutally hot sun that I need
to cover myself from so it just seemed
like the best uniform for the job oh
that is the mirror yeah so we have a
small windows so you can oh I'm scared
to breathe now what you can see it's the
washing unit basically it's the place
where we do the the stripping of the
coating and the washing before entering
the vacuum chamber right now we are in
the first step of the process which is
our first cleaning to remove all the
dust also all the stains that was
collected during two years by the mirror
and then we can start to do the
stripping or etching of the coating
using this rotating arm
to pour the acid and to have the layer
going out so wash the mirror to remove
the contaminants then acid etch the old
coating away and then when we have
cleaned the mirror and we will close
this big chamber do the vacuum and
deposit the aluminum you have
the heart of the machine
this is what we call the magnetron and
it's where we have the target of
aluminum
99.9 percent of aluminum very pure
that's Way Beyond what you'd normally
get for for industrial use and by the
way there is some shutters it is closed
so we cannot see the target the rainbow
colors are some deposition during the
process during years you have these thin
layers that's nice how much is being
added here the thickness of the coating
is around 0.1 micron
which is very very small and a micron is
a thousandth of a millimeter so that is
exactly one ten thousandth of a
millimeter you can basically count the
number of atoms there it's one thousand
atom Slayer one thousand
the weight it's around seven grams over
the entire eight meter mirror they
atomize aluminum to create the mirror
layer and when I say atomize I don't
mean like perfume sprayer atomizer I
mean literally they use plasma to make
individual atoms of aluminum float
around in a vacuum and then they just
let it softly rain down onto the mirror
until they have a coating about a
thousand atoms thick
anyway up at ut4 the Dome was opening so
this is going to point at the sky that's
obviously a lot more light than it would
normally get you have the shutter in
place so this you know black curtain
that you have here is there so no it's
just a physical black it's just a
physical blackout curtain okay yeah I
can see that just there and I just
noticed the guide star lasers I know
they've been there all the time they've
been really obvious but now it's pointed
this where I can see one two three four
giant laser emitters those are enormous
it's giant laser time but we can only
see that after the sun sets that's not
the ocean by the way those are clouds
we're above the clouds anyway sunsets
stars come out the Milky Way is just
stretched out above parallel and it is
so beautiful I've never seen the Stars
this clearly and they don't seem to
twinkle because there's less atmosphere
up here to cause that twinkling that
Distortion the atmosphere isn't one
consistent thing there are different
temperatures and pressures of air and
the light gets refracted it's not like
wind blowing balloons around the photons
of light aren't being blown away but
it's the same reason that an object in a
swimming pool looks distorted when you
look down at it from above the surface
that's a difference in the medium that
the light is traveling through the
different pockets of air that are
constantly moving about in the upper
atmosphere cause the same sort of effect
that's why the stars twinkle the light
is slightly bending its path as the
pockets of air move around that's the
reason that the telescope is built high
up on a desert mountain there is less
atmosphere to get in the way but there
is still some twinkling even if you
can't spot it myself enough that it
still cause problems with observations
and that's what the lasers are for the
lasers didn't look quite that right in
person there was a long exposure photos
but they looked cool enough and down in
the control room the scientists there
explain what they use them for this is
the laser control that's somewhere it's
like a status monitor where we can see
the status of the laser beacons which is
for images we see up here and also what
commands are being sent to the
deformable mirror to correct the
wavefront four lasers beamed out camera
scanning exactly what's happening to the
beams in terms of like just position is
it just finding the brightest dot in the
sky the lasers generate like a point
source that we can measure with the
wavefront sensor and the idea behind the
Adaptive Optics is to make that point
source as tight and as compact as
possible so we generate these artificial
Stars the laser beacons we measure them
we apply correction to the default
mirror and that hopefully improves the
quality of the laser Beacon and thus
improving the quality of the science
image every millisecond we're making a
measurement of the wavefront and it's
being commanded to the DSM what's the
line on that it's a few milliseconds but
the the DSM is like wibbling like this
really quickly yeah at a millisecond
that's absolutely amazing yeah why four
lasers so multiple lasers allows us to
correct the wavefront over a large area
on the sky providing like uniform image
quality across the science observation
if you only had one laser you would get
good correction in the middle but then
it would degrade as you go further out
and I figured of it a specific frequency
that you can then Notch out in the rest
of the observation this is that the
sodium wavelength on the instrument we
have a filter to filter out that light
also on the telescopes yeah on the guide
star so in short they shoot the laser up
see how it wobbles and then do maths to
subtract that wobble from the
observation look I'm going to say they
do maths at a few points during this
video because it's the sort of
calculation that people spend years
learning about suffice it to say they do
maths work out how the laser guide stars
are moving and then physically move and
distort the M2 mirror to subtract that
atmospheric Distortion from the actual
stuff they're looking at
so now you know how a modern optical
telescope works and how precise and
difficult the work is that's the first
thing you need to know to understand why
the extremely large telescope the new
one is probably the biggest that will
ever be built
the next day we're able to go down into
the basement underneath the four
telescopes because when I said that the
VLT was four unit telescopes yes it is
but they can all act as one called the
vlti very large telescope interferometer
there is a lot of competition for
biggest telescope in the world there's
things like the Event Horizon telescope
which is a network of radio telescopes
all around the globe they all point at
the same thing at the same time and
because they are so far apart on other
sides of the planet the astronomers can
record the data that's received analyze
it with signal processing algorithms and
supercomputers and do maths and create a
virtual telescope that is the size of
the planet that's called interferometry
because the maths is all about how those
signals interfere with each other we
basically completely change the way that
we handle the data and the minute we
start combining these beams we're
thinking about interfering waves of
light rather than an image and the
person we get from the interference of
that light is where we extract all of
the information that we want radio
astronomy can do that by recording the
radio waves and then processing it all
afterwards but remember how I said the
wavelength of radio is longer and the
telescopes don't have to be so precise
Well turns out a lot of other things
don't have to be so precise for that
either atmospheric variations are a huge
limitation for us in the optical because
you know the atmosphere is full of water
is full of Things That Vary very quickly
um at Optical and infrared wavelengths
the atmosphere is not varying so crazily
um at radio and some millimeter
wavelengths so you have you're able to
maintain all that phase information
doesn't get completely smeared out by
the atmospheric variations you know if
there's a party with a really loud sound
system a way away then you won't hear
the treble you won't hear the
but you will hear the thumb Thum thump
of the bass radio waves and
apologies to physicists watching this
but radio waves are the base of the
electromagnetic spectrum they travel
just fine through the atmosphere with
minimal Distortion that's why nobody
bothers sending radio telescopes into
space we don't need to but at Optical
frequencies it's different all the
information that you need to do
interferometry that information gets
smudged much more easily as it passes
through the atmosphere and that's not
even the worst problem for light there
is not a computer in the world fast
enough to deal with all that information
and there is not a clock in the world
precise enough even radio interferometry
requires very precise atomic clocks
synchronized across the globe but there
just isn't a clock in the world accurate
enough to do that for the micrometer
wavelengths or nanometer wavelengths and
terahertz frequencies of light a radio
wave you can just record it even before
digital computers were a thing you could
just record a radio wave onto Magnetic
Tape every single detail of it every
frequency every little Nuance everything
take a boom box from the 80s can do that
when people used to type songs off the
radio that is a very rough and imprecise
version of radio astronomy but for light
there is not a computer in the world
fast enough to record that data not with
the accuracy required for interferometry
so instead they do it physically in real
time remember what I said that the light
from the unit telescopes could be sent
off to the equipment to the side or down
to the basement let's go see the
basement so where are we headed now we
are going to say what we call those
uncurable means
elbow in French okay
so I'm guessing from the name that this
is a movable joint a hinge that can
change the direction of the light yes
that's a serious warning sign that is
oh
okay well and there's a telescope and we
are under what we call the kudipath and
this is really where we receive the
light which will be let's call it
organized in order to bring it towards
of LTI the light comes into each of the
telescopes it gets bounced around the
mirrors of the delay tunnel gets
funneled into the blti lab gets funneled
into the instrument and that's where it
gets combined so the light beam isn't
recorded anywhere it's bounced into tiny
tunnels from each telescope and its next
stop is a 150 meter long human
accessible tunnel to synchronize all the
beams the delay lines so these tunnels
run all the way from all the telescopes
to a central point oh
so you cannot trust his side of the
thinking of the real okay my entire body
used to say this is the boundary all
right thank you sorry okay so I'm not
going to go near their equipment if I'm
told not to but in my head I'm like
that's that's a little strange that
looks like fairly heavy infrastructure
surely it can't do any damage if I
accidentally just bump up against it
well the light arrives in the delay
lines in that tunnel from the side it
hits a series of mirrors designed to
synchronize all the beams and each beam
is bounced up the tunnel to one of the
carriages and reflected back so how
precise does that have to be
I can show you okay
we use the delay lens for observation
and you can see here the error
136 nanometers I assume that the
carriage would be accurate to like maybe
a millimeter and then there'd be some
electronics and mirrors in there that
would do the the nanometer correction
but is is that Carriage accurate to like
100 nanometers in its
positions
I understand why why I got told not to
even get close to that line that's
incredible the carriages can be moved
with a hundred nanometers of precision
100 nanometers that's why they didn't
want me near them they'll have to
recalibrate each night anyway of course
it'll get clean from time to time but
they don't want some idiot potentially
bumping into things that have to be 100
nanometers accurate because that's how
they delay the light and do Optical
inferometry that's how everything is
synchronized no recording no playback no
computers analyzing things it's analog
it's physical
explaining what happens in the science
part of that inside the freezing cold
vacuum of science stuff in the rest of
the lab is Way Beyond me that's the
stuff astronomy phds are made of and
it's still a lot of work to record the
interference patterns and work back from
that but if all those beams are
synchronized enough it means they can
approximate a telescope the size of the
entire VLT platform all four unit
telescopes instead of just the
individual telescope mirrors but all
those telescopes for optical have to be
physically connected
so we've covered interferometry we've
covered the mirrors and resurfacing and
we've covered the sheer scale of these
telescopes you now know everything you
need to know to work out why the elt the
extremely large telescope will probably
be the largest optical telescope ever
constructed and that elt is our final
stop
if you're wondering why I'm rocking the
extremely fashionable combination of
awful raggedy old baseball cap that I
found in my check baggage and uh hoodie
up uh the altitude is about three
kilometers here the UV index is just yes
because that's one of the reasons they
built here we are as close to the chubby
atmosphere as you can reasonably get so
guys oh we've actually got a name safety
gear in our size okay there we go
require protective equipment up here
helmet gloves Hive is steel toe cap
boots
and Factor 50 sunblock the construction
site is 20 kilometers away down the hill
that the VLT is on up the next one it is
colossal and it looks so much closer
than it is my brain refused to admit
that a telescope Dome could be that big
the construction is 74 meters high 86
meters in diameter and that
that is the extremely large telescope
the main mirror the M1
39.2 meters in diameter comprised of 798
hexagonal Partners we make the biggest
Optical mirror ever built that is
so lost so we are expecting images five
times sharper than Giant's web telescope
it is in outer space
five times sharper than the James the
one that's like out there yeah beyond
the atmosphere yeah exactly the first
reason that there's likely to be nothing
bigger than this is sheer cost the cost
line does not follow a linear
relationship but it goes exponential so
maybe you will add you say couple of
meters more and they cost double there
have been plans for bigger telescopes
there was something called the
overwhelmingly large telescope the owl
that was briefly planned it could happen
but it would cost tens of billions of
Euro and frankly the technology is
unproven
second reason we're reaching the limits
of what is physically possible with
current construction technology they're
engineering something that is part
telescope part skyscraper so it's lots
of different sections all working
together yeah all the sections are
working together and its geometry will
be readjusted through three actuators
per segment for a total number of
2394 actuators the eight meter mirrors
and the VLT they sag under their own
weight and granted the elt is using
mirror segments not a single monolithic
mirror but keeping them all aligned
isn't easy and the entire structure will
still stretch and warp as it's moved
around and with thermal expansions the
temperature changes this wall is
basically the hyper Foundation where on
top of it the telescope will be mounted
right so this is fixed to the ground and
on top of it there is hydraulic bearing
system that will be moving the telescope
how precise does that have to be for
those movements we are talking about
it's 100 slash 1000 depending on the
reservation of Arc sequence okay so what
does a thousandth of an arc secondary
precision mean I did some maths and it
means that this colossal skyscraper
telescope will move so smoothly and so
precisely that if you told it to look at
and track a spot on the moon it would be
accurate to within two meters the actual
Imaging resolution is not quite that
small it could image buildings about 10
meters across at that distance but again
that's a distance that can be measured
in light seconds we are at the limits of
what it's possible to do with current
technology and the last reason and I
think the most important one is that at
some point we're gonna solve Optical
interferometry people are working on it
right now it still has to be physical
computers aren't fast enough clocks
aren't precise enough
but they're only going to get better at
some point in the future we are probably
going to figure that out and we'll be
able to do Optical interferometry the
same way that we can do radio and as
soon as that happens the extremely large
telescope will be
not obsolete it'll still be useful for
some types of observations because there
are advantages to the size big
telescopes that you detect very small
things and very faint things
interferometry gets you the small stuff
but not the faint stuff because there's
less mirror surface for the light to
bounce off but odds are at some point
they'll be much cheaper and easier
virtual ways of making really big
telescopes the elt is still going to do
a hell of a lot of science before that
can happen if it ever does happen but
once that's done maybe in a few decades
maybe a century the case for building
something this big kind of goes away if
instead you can build a few small
telescopes and piece them all together
so this the extremely large telescope
will probably be the last of the great
optical telescopes I could be wrong who
knows maybe in a Century's time this
will seem ridiculous and there'll be a
100 meter mirror sitting high on a
plateau somewhere in South America
but if I had to place a bet I think
there's a very strong chance the elt
will be the largest optical telescope to
ever be built
and as I said earlier nordvpn was
extremely useful to me I have been using
it a lot because while I was in Chile
websites kept showing up in the wrong
language they're all like
plus over the last year or so I've saved
hundreds of dollars on car rental
because some rental companies charge way
less just depending on where they think
your computer is located same car same
contract same driving license same
everything I went all the way to the
final checkout to make sure I just
clicked nordvpn's magic button to say I
was back in the UK and suddenly I got a
rental for almost half price and of
course if you want to watch shows from
back home you can just check the
streaming services terms first you can
use nordvpn on six devices at the same
time across Windows Mac Linux IOS and
Android and there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee if you want to test it out
first if you go to nordvpn.com Tom Scott
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code then you'll get the
best deal they're currently offering
whenever you're watching this video